Spending time at the airport can get expensive,...
...but there are a few ways to save.
Hey guys, I'm Krystin Goodwin with Buzz60,...
...and here's how to spend 15 dollars or less at the airport.
Don't check your bag.
Even if I'm traveling for two weeks, I travel with a carry-on.
I hate paying for bag fees and I've had the airline lose my bag.
Avoid airport food.
Not only is it pricey, but it's not that tasty or good for you.
Bring a bag with a few snacks and plastic containers you can throw away.
Most of the time, you can get these through security.
You can't bring liquids, but you can bring an empty plastic bottle...
...and fill up at a filtered water fountain instead of buying pricey drinks.
Plus, once you get on the plane, drinks are pretty much unlimited.
If you get stuck or have a long layover, head to a restaurant chain.
A small meal will cost you around the same as that random kiosk sandwich,...
...but it'll probably taste better.
Bring your own travel medicines and gum.
These are also costly at the airport.
And bring headphones so you don't have to purchase the ones from the airline.
So, make a plan to save.
Traveling is wonderful, but so is saving money.
Buzz60: Now you know, pass it on.